[Applause]
keep everyone back i'm here to help you
this looks like attention pneumothorax i
need to borrow this sorry
he saved it
who is this kid my daughter the doctor
earlier today a man's life was saved by
a local teen doctor dr kamehameha will
be taking care of you aloha mr lin is
this some kind of practical joke you
know who she's like remember doogie
houser that show from the 90s she's like
a real life dookie houser that's why we
call her doogie i never made the
connection girl why did you think we
called her too
in a moment being a 16 year old doctor
is kind of like having a superpower
doctor may i have a word with you and
you got a little something right mom
gross well are you hungry
i love you doctor it's impossible to
work with lahella and be her mom she
shuts me out i was hoping we could take
the car i'm afraid not a second ago you
were my boss you don't get to control my
entire life
i held a man's heart in my hand
yesterday i work so hard and get nothing
a little doctor sister has so much to
learn i think she just needs a room to
make mistakes like all teenagers i'm
afraid she's missing out nothing's gonna
stop me nothing's gonna stop me now
tomorrow night will be my first date
with walter
hey
hi
have fun you two
i kissed walter
i'm a doctor now and it's not fair that
i get all that pressure but none of the
fun
i just feel so ready for everything
you are extraordinary
you're just saying that because you're
my mom
i'm saying it because it's true
[Music]
the science supports my hypothesis
walter likes me
science science science can you guys get
out of here it's my xbox time
only on disney plus